gardez la france au fond des yeux
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils en apprennent
à tricoter d'accord là-dessus à votre
place je la ramène un peu moins mais si
vous ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il vous
manque qu'une seule chose un tout petit
détail le trophée des valises à paris de
ce qui lui arrive à la baisse
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cet
inattendu de l'entre-deux tours
aujourd'hui grâce aux archives de la
télévision
nous allons remonter le temps de
l'affichage électoral et de l'abstention
céline braconnier est notre invitée elle
nous parlera de celles et ceux qui ne
votent pas il était encore un petit peu
plus de 12 millions 800 mille dimanche
dernier mais d'abord notre revue de
presse avec géraldine corner lavaud et
avec camille d'auxerre bonjour à toutes
les deux jours alors géraldine on
commence avec un anniversaire oui un
anniversaire ça fait 50 ans 50 ans cette
année que le rapport milloz a été publié
c'était en 1972 quatre étudiants de
l'université des métiers à boston sommes
la première alerte pour la planète terre
c'était très clair dans leur rapport ils
concluent avec ses terme dévorer par sa
soif de croissance l'humanité court à sa
perte voilà on peut pas être plus clair
c'était un rapport commandé par le club
de rome et le club de rome à sa tête il
y avait aurelio petchey y écouter le
c'était en 1973 le vrai problème est
qu'il faut trouver un compromis entre la
croissance de la population qui
peut-être n'est pas frais nabeul dans
dans les prochaines dix ou quinze années
et notre utilisation des ressources
terrestres il ya des ressources qui sont
épuisables qui ne peut pas être
renouvelé
c'est ce cet équilibre entre populations
production ressources espaces
disponibles qu'il faut trouver et
trouver assez rapidement sinon si nous
faisons pas ça nos fils nos notes
les prochaines générations devront payer
notre imprévoyance notre égoïsme voilà
c'était plutôt clair à son message le
monde il ya 50 ans était donc un
tournant pendant qu'ils auraient pu être
pris si les politiques avaient écouté
ces scientifiques on le rappelle le giec
a publié il ya quelques jours son
dernier rapport selon eux il il n'y a
plus de place au doute c'est maintenant
qu'il faut agir voilà maintenant à
l'actualité environnementale au coeur de
notre actualité politique et de
l'élection présidentielle camille la
prochaine étape de ce scrutin c'est le
débat de l'entre-deux tours oui mercredi
20 avril et un débat de l'entre-deux
tours et bien ça se prépare alors les
équipes des candidats vont certainement
multiplié les conseils auprès d'
emmanuel macron et de marine le pen pour
réussir le débat de l'entre-deux tours
pour savoir réagir aussi à des questions
embarrassantes car il y en aura de place
tellement mercredi prochain ça peut
arriver alors un conseil à suivre celui
donné en
1977 par jean amadou alors en face d'une
question embarrassante le premier
principe c'est
le sou il ne faut pas lâcher le sourire
de jamais donner l'impression à
l'adversaire qui était été touché alors
tu vas me pose est par exemple question
embarrassante et on va voir comment un
homme politique essaie de s'en sortir
dans ces moments-là vas-y post-bac ratio
masse alors comment comptez-vous
diminuer le prix du pain et augmenter le
prix du blé pour les agriculteurs voilà
alors tu vois le sourire et en même
temps si tu pouvais entendre ma voix
intérieure que tu n'entends pas bien sûr
ma pensée c'est à la vache
ah les [ __ ]
comment j'ai rien là dessus ils m'ont
rien donné alors voilà on ne lâche pas
le sourire nathanaël et on peut revoir
ce sketch en intégralité sur le site de
l'ina un sketch de 77 qui n'a pas prise
uniquement voilà l'actualité de la
semaine alors que s'est il passé à cette
même période les années précédentes à
écouter ces happenings de l'inattendu
regarde
bonjour
la plus ancienne course du pays une
grande fête qui tourne au cauchemar une
violente déflagration un mouvement de
panique une bombe vient d'exploser sur
la ligne d'arrivée du marathon de bost
21 films que j'ai tournés 16 ou 17
d'entre eux traiter du problème racial
je suis maintenant fatigué dans ce genre
de rôle je voudrais faire quelque chose
d'autre je ne voudrais pas que ma
carrière d'acteur à son de la couleur
soit limité à ce genre de rôle
un visage presque méconnaissable celui
de julian assange le fondateur de
wikileaks est arrêté ce matin en 2010 il
avait publié sur wikileaks des milliers
de documents confidentiels du
département d'état et du pentagone pour
cela il risque jusqu'à cinq ans de
prison
des milliers d'anonymes venus de toute
l'europe ont fait le siège du parc dès
6h ce matin impatients de découvrir ce
nouveau monde à l'américaine dépaysement
assuré par 29 attraction très bien rodé
ils étaient venus pour les gosses ils
sont sous le charme subjugué par le
souci du détail de la machine 10 d une
épaisse fumée s'échappe de la cathédrale
notre dame on aperçoit des flammes
sortir du toit et le panache est visible
de très loin c'est peut-être une un
conte de fées c'est peut-être un compte
de bons ou de mauvais génie l'avenir
nous le dira mais enfin c'est la course
au bonheur et vive le progrès bonsoir
[Musique]
dans ce printemps électoral
elles fleurissent un petit peu partout
un les affiches de campagne même à
l'heure des réseaux sociaux restent
omniprésentes et derrière ces affiches
collées de ci de là cherradi il y à de
longues batailles et des stratégies pour
les militants et bien sûr pour les
parties évidemment alors il y a les
affiches des sur les panneaux officiels
qu'on a vu un devant les bureaux de vote
avant ces affiches étaient collés par
des militants manque de militants
aujourd'hui elles le sont par des
sociétés privées c'est la société france
affiche + qui a décroché le marché
depuis 2015 mais en dehors de ces
espaces réglementaire et bien il y à la
rue le champ de bataille voir le chant
de guerre des militants parce qu'il ya
vraiment une guerre entre colleurs
d'affichés et ils ont des techniques
bien particulière parce que coller une
affiche de campagne et bien c'est tout
un art
la colle larmes par excellence du
colleur d'affichés savants mélanges
d'eau de sucre et de farine et pour
compléter la panoplie un ballet des
affiches et c'est parti pour coller et
décoller reconnaît on y va la nuit à
nouveau ajourné
samedi le dimanche si aujourd'hui les
affiches des panneaux officiels sont
collés par des sociétés privées la rue
reste le domaine des militants il y a
des espaces autorisés ce qui t'a fait un
collage autorisé mais depuis toujours
les militants tous partis confondus
outre passe de la loi écoles en dehors
des panneaux qui leur sont réservés à
notre chantier boîte aux lettres boîtier
les cliques arrondi d'une colonne toutes
les surfaces de la ville sont investis
l'enjeu reste est visible le plus
longtemps possible pour ça plusieurs
techniques premier point l'emplacement
être visibles ont collé sur des sur des
endroits où il ya beaucoup de passage
lieu de passage mais aussi lieu en
hauteur pour rester coller sans être
décollé ni recouvert il a fallu voyez
les grands moyens de long col et très
haut pour rester en collectant et le
procureur de décoller d'autres décident
de coller la nuit
les jeunes militants du rpr n'ont pas
lésiné sur la colle mille affiches ont
été posées cette nuit dans les rues de
rennes à quelques heures de la venue de
jacques chirac erreur de débutant pour
ce militant ps
pour matinée
parce que
matinée vous restez au moins quelques
heures car le filet ennemi du colleur
d'affichés c'est l'autre colleurs
d'affichés il se livre à un jeu sans fin
collé par dessus les affiches des
candidats concurrents forcément il ya
plus me chevènement
mais j'espère pour que les parts de
suspense qu'elles vont devenir plus
longtemps même si les couleurs du fn
sont des bons colère faut le reconnaître
aussi mais dans cette guéguerre il y a
parfois des alliances
on est plus ou moins sympathiques arto
noras le relais pays
ils le font aussi avec nous coller
recoller par dessus cette surenchère
d'affiche a forcément des conséquences
en 1974 une fois la campagne terminée
ces militants prenait les choses en main
pour tout nettoyer nous avons été pris
dans l'escaladé du collage et maintenant
nous nous sommes rendus compte qu'il
valait mieux des collègues c'était donc
plus honneur conformité avec nos
principes cette initiative restera bien
isolé ce sont les municipalités qui
prennent en charge le nettoyage et la
note peut s'avérer salée alors certaines
communes ont pris des décisions
radicales lors de la présidentielle de
2017 en france plusieurs villes ont
déclaré la guerre au placard sauvage
c'est le cas à lille ou encore ici à
toulouse 12 euros par affiches facturés
aux partis politiques en 2017 toulouse a
dressé pour 30000 euros damende pour
affichage électoral y
voit là on est d'accord un géraldine
l'affichage sauvage est interdit et il
n'y a pas que les parties 1 qui risque
de payer des amendes effectivement si
vous dégradez une affiche sur un panneau
officiel ce devant les bureaux de vote
vous risquez une amende de 450 euros on
voit un l'allée des boosts achats
mélenchon a un gros nez marine le pen en
voldemort mais petit conseil si vous
laisser exprimer votre art de la
caricature sur des affiches collées de
façon sauvage là vous ne risquez rien
voilà vous êtes prévenus au delà vous
regardez des gribouillages pour certains
le détournement des affiches électorales
c'est de l'art effectivement exactement
ces deux là et c'est le cas cette année
d'un artiste qui s'appelle jérémy c'est
un artiste de rue vous avez peut-être vu
ces détournements il en a placardées un
peu partout à paris à reims à nantes
juste en bas de chez camille par exemple
tout apprécié voir emmanuel macron
éborgné en gilet jaune marine le pen
avec un voile ou encore valérie pécresse
en défense du mariage pour tout pour
tous son message était de dénoncer les
politiques qui stigmatisent certaines
communautés merci beaucoup gérard limât
grâce à vous on va regarder les affiches
électorales
différemment regardera d'ailleurs si
l'artiste a pas signé en bas à droite on
sait
[Musique]
un électeur sur quatre s'est donc
abstenue au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle dimanche dernier cela
représente 26 3 % des inscrits sur les
listes électorales qu'en sera-t-il au
second tour on va en parler avec céline
braconnier notre invité bonjour vous
êtes professeur de sciences politiques
directrice de sciences po saint germain
en laye écho aux tris de la démocratie
de l'abstention c'est aux éditions folio
une abstention record était donc attendu
c'est à dire plus que le
28,4 de 2002 que s'est il passé comment
expliquer cette mobilisation de dernière
minute c'est le propre d'une campagne et
les taux et les cte orale que d'être
capable dans les tous derniers jours de
convaincre ceux qui ne sont pas sûrs de
vouloir y aller que c'est un sens d'y
aller et là j'ai envie de dire que les
sondages ont joué un rôle important dans
la remobilisation en montrant que les
écarts se resserraient entre les trois
candidats qui étaient susceptibles
d'être au second tour donc tout d'un
coup au dernier moment le déplacement a
repris du sens parce qu'évidemment aller
voter quand les jeux sont déjà faits ça
n'a pas beaucoup de sens notamment pour
les gens qui sont assez loin de la
politique et qui comprennent pas
pourquoi ils devraient se déplacer si
les jeux sont déjà joué alors en tout
cas kabyle depuis l'instauration du
suffrage universel direct en 1962
l'abstention la présidentielle ça fait
partie de la vie pour nous et ça fait
partie du jeu dès la première élection
en 1965 des français s'abstiennent déjà
aux alentours de 15% ça fait un peu
rêver ce score aujourd'hui est un spot à
la télévision pendant l'entre-deux-tours
ainsi que les français justement à
retourner voter comme ils l'ont fait au
premier tour et même à aller plus loin
dans le jeu démocratique en participant
au dépouillement après le second tour et
lecteurs et lectrices lors du premier
tour des élections présidentielles vous
avez accompli en masse votre devoir
électoral dimanche prochain à nouveau
vous allez voter mais vous pourrez faire
plus en participant vous aussi au
dépouillement des votes votre présence
dans les bureaux de vote et mieux encore
votre participation active aux
opérations de dépouillement en assurera
la régularité
alors en 1965 au second tour
l'abstention est quasi identique vous le
voyez c'est la colonne en jaune environ
15% dans ce spot on monte le citoyen
modèle est ce que c'était ça veut dire
que l'abstentionniste étant mauvais
citoyens à l'époque alors il ya une
approche morale de la participation
électorale
qui est pas nouvelle 1 depuis
l'instauration du suffrage universel
la république vise à construire des
citoyens modèles c'est à dire des
citoyens qui sont capables de donner un
peu de temps pour les autres et pour la
vie républicaine donc ça se traduit
notamment au moment de la mise en place
du suffrage universel pour l'élection
présidentielle par une incitation à
participer là les français découvrent
cette élection du président en direct
par le parler se ferait universel et il
ya une incitation à donner de son temps
à être assesseurs à à venir aider au
dépouillement des urnes au-delà du fait
de voter mais voyez bien qu'on est
au-delà l'essentiel est déjà assurée
puisque lé 15 % d'abstention ce sont les
gens malades qui peuvent pas se déplacer
qui se sont abstenus mais globalement
c'est la france aux urnes qu'on voit
mise en scène dans ses images alors en
tout cas camille l'image du citoyen
modèle que l'on découvre en 1965 celui
qui vote qui dépouillent les bulletins
cette image va vite s'effondrait oui dès
dès l'élection présidentielle suivante
en 1969 alors là vous allez le voir
scénario inédit au 1er tour 22 4 %
d'abstention et au second tour 31,1 pour
cent le paysage politique ces deux
candidats s'affrontent alain poher
georges pompidou ils sont politiquement
assez proches l'un de l'autre droite
centre droite georges pompidou donc à
gauche alain poher à droite à l'image
est le troisième homme de l'élection
surtout à ce moment là c'est le
communiste jacques duclos au premier
tour il fait plus de 20% et il appelle à
quoi il appelle à l'abstention entre
power et pompidou et il va utiliser une
expression qui va être très populaire
pour les abstentionnistes et encore
aujourd'hui on ne choisit pas entre
bonnet blanc et blanc bonnet la
bourgeoisie de notre pays
les entrants sommes deux candidats qui
sont des cousins germains
si ce n'est des frères siamois si vous
voulez suivre mes conseils
pour ne voter ni pour le pompidou dix
poules pour
[Applaudissements]
dire à ses soutiens de choisir
l'abstention c'est devenu impossible
aujourd'hui oui alors ça n'est pas dit
aussi ouvertement parce qu'on enregistre
aujourd'hui des taux d'abstention
tellement important à toutes les
élections que c'est plus audible un
appel par des professionnels de la
politique à ne pas aller voter en
revanche ne pas inciter à voter à
l'occasion du second tour à se prononcer
pour un candidat c'est une incitation ou
sa rampe ou et c'est la porte ouverte
trois jours mais dans les deux cas dans
ce dans ce fait historique ce qu'on
remarque c'est que l'incitation à ne pas
voter elle est liée au fait que le choix
n'est pas réel puisqu'on n'a pas de
représentant de la gauche à l'occasion
de ce second tour et donc ça enlève du
sens disons aux déplacements pour pour
duclos et c'est une situation qui est
resté dans tous les cas porteuse
d'abstention alors la bonne nouvelle
c'est que cette abstention de
1969 baisse ça reste notre pic personnel
électoral ça n'est plus jamais arrivé
depuis un lieu non pas en tout cas
l'élection suivante en 1974 elle
enregistre le plus faible taux
d'abstention comme quoi rien n'est gravé
dans le marbre au premier tour de 74
l'abstention elle est de 15 8% au second
elle est de 12,7 pourquoi et bien parce
que là le clivage et net c'est le duel
entre mitterrand et vge une des raisons
aussi qui fait qu' il n'y a pas eu une
énorme abstention c'est que dès 1973 on
a bien compris que l'abstention elle
fait partie de la présidentielle et on
ne dit plus aux français venez jouer le
rôle d'assesseur en l'ordi tout
simplement aller voter
tous les partis entreprennent avec les
moyens les plus modernes efforts
considérables pour réduire le nombre des
abstentionnistes car leurs voix seront
précieuses votez votez oui vingtaine ont
voté x ou y mais votez pour une raison
dans un pays comme la france ou la
droite et la gauche s'équilibrent à peu
près quelques milliers de voix peut
faire basculer une majorité l'abstention
a deux visages celui du refus politique
celui de l'indifférence à la politique a
récompensé de la politique voyage
ce soir de droite de gauche au milieu
c'est pareil c'est très simple et pas
friand dire bon pote mon nez française
voyant a alors
oui il faut voter les français on parle
un peu de l'abstentionniste comme d'une
personne qui refuse de faim de
s'intéresser à la politique qui est
complètement indifférent est-ce que je
vous donne un petit challenge mais est
ce que en trois quatre lignes on arrive
à avoir un peu le profil type de
l'abstentionniste en france c'est plutôt
quelqu'un qui a des caractéristiques
sociodémographiques assez marquées
quelqu'un de jeune et plus on est jeune
plus on a du mal à se déplacer pour
aller voter on est dans un âge de la vie
où on hésite on se projette pas
forcément dans les institutions
c'est quelqu'un de milieux populaires
peu diplômés il ya un lien entre ces
caractéristiques sociales et la
propension à participer alors autre
statistique remarquable depuis 74 et
jusqu'au début 2000 finalement
l'abstention n'a cessé de progresser en
france oui alors elle progresse toujours
au 1er tour vous le voyez avec ce
graphique elle est toujours un tout
petit peu moins importante au second
tour mon ca s'explique un an on va voter
contre un candidat au second tour
l'offre est plus réduite mais c'est un
fait l'abstention grimpe en france
écoutez roland cayrol politologue qui en
1995 explique cette progression il ya un
discours qui est en train de s'installer
selon lequel la force de la moralité
c'est du côté de ceux qui s'abstiennent
les promesses non tenues ça va de soi
dans la politique dans ces cons là dans
ces conditions le devoir ce le devoir de
vigilance c'est de ne pas participer à
leur jeu c'est de ne pas y aller ça
c'est terrible parce que l'argument du
civisme et totalement renversé il émis
au profit de ceux qui disent faut pas
participer que s'est il passé dans les
années 80 90 pour que le civisme soit
synonyme d'abstention non alors moi je
ne suis pas d'accord avec cette analyse
il s'est passé que l'alternance
droite gauche a suscité du
désenchantement de la délices de la
désillusion et de l'éloignement des
urnes ça c'est le premier élément il ya
un facteur politique qui explique la
hausse de de l'abstention et puis il ya
des facteurs sociaux on est dans un
monde qui se transforme et notamment le
monde industriel qui se déstructure et
qui est porteur de désaffiliation
politique syndical et tout ça ça laisse
des gens
finalement plus seul face à la
participation au plan politique oui les
orphelins politique en quelque sorte et
le relais n'est pas pris part aucune
autre institution ni par les cols dont
le rôle est encore à questionner
aujourd'hui et ça ça revient à laisser
les familles
socialiser politiquement leur leurs
membres et selon que vous êtes né dans
une famille politisés ou non vous avez
plus ou moins de chances d'aller
participer à un scrutin puis camilia le
choc l'électrochoc même en 2002 oui et
son abstention record jamais dépassé 28
4 % au premier tour on connaît la suite
le duel chirac le pen ça réveille les
abstentionnistes du premier tour et
l'abstention donc au second tour
s'effondre de huit points passant à
environ 20% mais dans l'entre-deux-tours
ce qu'on a vu en 2002 ce sont des
abstentionnistes qui se sont pressés
pour faire leur procuration
certains abstentionnistes hante
semble-t-il de se rattraper entre
guillemets au lendemain du premier tour
on s'empresse en effet de remplir les
formulaires de procuration
la présence de jean-marie le pen au
deuxième tour a fait réagir bon nombre
d'électeurs c'est important après ce qui
s'est passé au premier tour que les
français râlent et ça en glace et fasse
barrage au front national
je crois que beaucoup de personnes comme
moi vont regretter de ne pas avoir douté
parce que parce que c'est notre devoir
et je n'ai pas fait mon devoir voilà
j'ai honte alors en 2002 on a vu
énormément de manifestations dans le
pays quand avec l'extrême droite aux
portes du pouvoir est ce que cette année
elle est charnière dans l'histoire de
l'abstention est ce qu'on a gros on a
compris l'importance du vote à ce
moment-là c'est la première fois qu'on
s'approche présidentielle de 30 %
d'abstention à part le cadre du deuxième
tour de 2,69 donc évidemment ça a
réveillé les consciences à redonner du
sens au vote et met ça en même temps ça
n'a pas duré a donc voilà on ce qui est
sûr c'est que 2002 joue un rôle de
culpabilisation des abstentionnistes est
ce qui est marquant aujourd'hui c'est
que ceux qui s'abstiennent le plus les
plus jeunes le culpabiliser plus de
s'abstenir ne considère pas vraiment le
vote comme un devoir mais d'abord comme
un droit et n'accepte d'y aller que
s'ils trouvent du sens et plupart par
devoir seulement lordon sujet on parle
aussi de la lourdeur administrative pour
voter par procuration
est ce que ça joue on ne réglera pas la
question de l'abstention avec des
améliorations procédurale mais c'est un
levier tout de même pour rendre possible
la participation au dernier moment il ya
aujourd'hui il ya une partie de la
procédure qui est dématérialisé mais
vous devez quand même vous déplacer pour
aller pour notre identité au
commissariat la gendarmerie dans un
tribunal d'instance est donc faux faut
vraiment vouloir voter pour le faire et
donc ça exclut toutes les populations
qui sont assez loin de la politique et
qui sont prêtes à y aller quand c'est
facile mais qui ne feront pas l'effort
supplémentaire de ces procédures
compliquées en tout cas la
présidentielle de 2002 sert vraiment
d'électrochoc un prêt puisque camille
les les français reprennent le chemin
disait oui reprennent vie reprenne pays
reprenne le chemin de l'isoloir mais
pour un ton parce que vous voyez de 2000
cas vont un peu plus qu'avant mais
l'abstention elle reste toujours entre
16 et 20 21% et puis donc en 2017 on
passe à plus de 22 % d'abstention au
premier tour et surtout plus encore au
second tour
25,4 pour cent les français comment 69
n'ont pas voulu faire de choix en france
plus de 25 % des électeurs ont choisi
l'abstention un record depuis 1969 alors
j'ai toujours voté jusqu'à présent mais
là je savais que de voter pour l'un pour
l'autre c'était nourrir l'un ou l'autre
quoi qu'il arrive et et comme je me
compte ce n'est ni le libéralisme nil
affichage et peintre l'aprécial choléra
je veux pas pour le
mégawatt
2012-2017 les français ont clairement
changé l'extrême droite ne déplacent
plus les abstentionnistes au second tour
non c'est plus suffisamment mobilisateur
il ya tout une partie de la population
pour qui voilà le la perspective de
l'exercice du pouvoir par l'extrême
droite les frais n'effraie plus en tout
cas c'est plus suffisant pour pour
mobiliser et est-ce qu'il ya un seuil un
pourcentage d'abstention après lequel au
delà duquel on va devoir rendre le vote
obligatoire parce que se posera un vrai
problème démocratique alors ça pose un
problème démocratique l'abstention parce
que plus l'abstention est élevé plus les
inégalités sociales de participation
sont fortes ça poserait moins de
problèmes si tout le monde de
s'abstenait de la même façon mais c'est
pas le cas et donc avant de rendre le
vote obligatoire
il ya quand même d'autres modalités
d'autres réformes a tenté d'autres
changements apportés dans les manières
de faire de la politique pour essayer de
réenchanter finalement la démocratie
représentative
merci beaucoup céline braconnier je
rappelle que vous êtes directrice de
sciences po saint germain en laye et
auteur qu aux tris de la démocratie de
l'abstention c'est aux éditions folio
merci à vous on termine avec notre
traditionnel pépites de l'inattendu
piocher dans les archives de l'ina
consacré bien sûr à l'abstention a
forcément aujourd'hui avec une petite
phrase de jean gabin une petite phrase
dont il avait le secret écouté par
exemple que je comprends pas
par exemple depuis que j'ai l'âge de
raison qu'ils comprendront les
républiques les machins et où tu as voté
et balais et gras ils continuent à voter
tant que ça peut et chaque coup c'est
pareil
moi je vois tu pas
peur je subis voilà on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine sur le canal 27 et
toute la semaine sur les réseaux sociaux
que ce soit sur france info ou ceux de
l'ina émission préparée avec les
documentalistes elisabeth jacquinot et
les honneurs prévost corlieu et anne
brûlant merci également à toute l'équipe
qui a participé à cette émission et
merci à vous d'être là chaque semaine à
vous étiez plus de
250000 à nous regarder samedi dernier un
record pour les nets
[Musique]